hello everybody and welcome back to him
he said the Dark Descent part 3 thank
you guys for tuning in and thank you
guys most of all for all the support on
this series it's been incredible
cool let's keep going everybody oh geez
says I keep forgetting about that bear
why not
[ __ ] okay I know where to go all right
so if you don't remember we made a pot
of acid if that was me I will just drink
it be done with it you know and if we
remember we got a par for the pot on the
on the goo yeah there you go
be gone with the pot you know what I try
to say oh man um let's let's see what's
next
I think I remember but I'm not sure no
wait what is this
it sure is dark in here yes sherry the
reason for it but you can like the left
now thank you
what's the reason for the darkness that
is stay close be careful not to stray
what's the reason why does it sit down
pay attention Daniel it's important that
you keep going straight and make sure
not to stray whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa what is happening
go straight
don't strain got it walk straight don't
stray the thing is I have no [ __ ]
clue what straying means let's do it
boys easy Oh God
enemies are near oh I remember this is
the blue jet black okay I don't remember
[Music]
what have I done to deserve this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
this is actually I remember this is the
first time you could actually die in the
game I think I'm not sure I know this
like I remember that was a threshold are
those apples hell yeah man it's okay
nope
[Music]
hey Apple so we meet again how about
that
she's Louise all right let's just take
it slow guys nice and easy all right
this door huh yep come I got him to fat
barrels okay
don't win stool and neither there we go
Oh
Dublin oh my god I'm up Jesus Christ I'm
have I learned nothing yeah don't stray
that was what I supposed to do which it
means don't go oh Jesus I thought he was
gonna come in here
it's just so dark and loud I get just a
natural reaction to all these things
chair you chair God I'm like I'm upset
with myself now I remember this that's
like a there it is
see I do remember some stuff Oh God
no one earth did I get through this game
the first time I played it it's
terrifying
it's like oldest sounds its pokes me
isn't that right well oh you were
blocking the door no wonder I hate Bal
I remember this puzzle but I can't lift
it I got a screw it just like my women
am i right
bazinga ha ha bye dunks sex jokes are
still funny feelings after eight years
it's funny how I thought it was six
years ago since I played this game Oh
God here goes nothing
all right Thank You GU for helping me
jump down okay all right I'm going we're
fine
we're absolutely fine
it's coming it's coming boys and girls
we're in elusive Channel
[Music]
it can't be that bad
oh god no I forgot okay here we go
so we meet again huh Oh Chinese my
ladder yeah yes
get up gasps sighs she buried ants Hey
is there anything in there I'll take aah
I'll take my chance what that break I
gotta get over there yeah we're fine
stop following me all right
I remember I can distract him a me gully
your vein three hip
I
no nope oh god did I just trap myself
that way I gotta throw
look butt
50 shades of gray fanfiction
Oh nearly got to me and holy geez that
was obnoxious
get up get up get up get up get up get
up
it's don't fine it's cool it's cool
brash take it back right I like on my
impression of myself in the past is just
nothing like what I think it is stop
[ __ ] up your jump and stop swearing
idiot oh no listen levar you gotta pull
just laughing all right that's oh I was
a [ __ ] timer did he make it in god
I'm on the side of oil where is the
lever then stop messing up the job
[Music]
there
where's the lever it's here somewhere is
it in the beginning no I'm getting
really good at jumping that oh there it
is great
[Music]
be quiet game
hop hop hop get a tow get it'll crema
Kremlin laughs Oh white
Hey all right you can you had a shortcut
good for you good for you you want a
snack
you like leg you like leg here you go
[Music]
now who's a good boy who's a good boy
you want men George so
[Music]
you know I'll bring the hand I'll bring
the hand you never know when you need a
hand
I need stop being so loud and horrible
like I'm trying to chill okay
keep meeting over there cuz I need pop I
need some time
okay
I have to pull that stupid thing
be a man
take the leg and leave me in the hell
longer no no no no no all right that
made it holy [ __ ] circular motion
no you're pulling it the wrong way
a joint please where's that
[ __ ] weed no this is stressing me vet
how did anyone played no that was a that
was a easy oh all right
doing pretty good Syl water all right
let's keep going
I assume something's gonna blow out
he's after me so far no 1 0-0 Deaf's
everybody wait no no God
god
go
Brow's okay I gotta run run run run run
run don't look back oh nothing going on
here nothing scared oh I look scared I'm
scared I'm scared I'm scared I'm scared
it's not bad yourself at me so I'm kind
mean that's not bad you oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
don't fit chairs
[Music]
Oh God Jade says Christ we're fine
absolutely fine and breathe okay
okay
Oh
Oh what the hell
that is definitely an interesting
fountain I was oh hello baby face by me
I missed baby face and legs long time no
see huh why not
flip flip flip there nothing like a good
good old baby face with links
here we are this the new hub area I
remember this place just cuz it's so
this game really new pacing they really
know how to like him
do it properly they know when to scare
you and when not to scary I think the
contrast is very important and they hit
it really well if it's just scary all
the time it says obnoxious
you have an ascending room would it take
us to the inner sanctum it will
definitely take care of the vertical
part of our journey so you have written
an elevator before yes the Colosseum a
Regents Park as well it takes you to the
gallery where you can view the panorama
during this ride might be a little
longer and in the other direction so
we're going deep deep down
it's like underneath the very stone some
brending bug I don't think it works yeah
I remember that stop wasting your land
you [ __ ]
machine Olsen huh the game kind of
pointed us here though I know there is
one of the rooms upstairs I think it's
this one it's strange I remember just
bits and pieces this is study and I do
believe we might meet a little furry
fandom in here except he has no hair
it's fine we're fine everything is fine
just you gotta have a positive positive
outlook on life isn't that right chair
chair agrees isn't that right hammer hey
your note everybody and a dead dog hey
road the lark folks okay all right
Canis lupus familiaris familiaris 1658
April 12th animal experiment after a
short study it was it is clear that
there a gadget ation found among humans
can be found in the dog fear and pain
induced stress which seem to trigger an
endo genuis endo genuis response causing
the animal to burst with energy I
believe that the catalyst is produced in
the brain it is difficult to determine
exactly where and what it is but I can
sense it it reeks of cosmic Genesis
there is an inherent problem in
harvesting the entity since the creature
is bound to die from the exercise I must
refine this process of torture to enable
any real work to be done more
experiments must be performed but it
seems Ness it seems that only human
beings are able to produce the amount
necessary it might be their ability to
appreciate the several severity of the
process that ultimately augments their
experience of terror not a real about
not nor can I trim brother Felix pretty
please let's go brach oh hell yeah I was
never a character in the original series
the best of my time to shine
I think I could be a really good part of
the sander man I think people are gonna
really like you can't a brother miss
Felix all right oh she says bones bounce
I tried to order Felix
Oh mother oh wow this is the painting
that of Alexander that can change that's
the half but oh oh my god and that to me
frontiers also known as Dick's 1658
January 9 further disappointment then to
Aquarians latest findings yielded
nothing I'm still unable to grasp the
inner workings of life and its relation
to the power I sense within it I shall
pursue more books on the subject but I
suspect it will be in vain since no
research has been made in my particular
interest I must attempt to filled that
for with myself clearly humans emanate
more of the energy I seek but I hope
animals supposed to Phi's as they would
prove less of a hassle to acquire
you sure had a tiny little ding a dingus
oh you hear the darks where did he go
nuts it brah
let's go there's where my cousin's son
Chester that is you can't Carla Felix
where do I go then I forgot how open my
oh that's right there find another way
around the stubble find the key that
unlocks the machine room alright so
there should be another way through good
good job Felix good job good job
I can't even find my no I'll be back all
right I'll be back it's just really dark
I do remember this puzzle actually I
need to throw something like a hammer or
dare wow what windows you have in here I
lent Oh
800 don't you're it ah thank you for
sparing my life
I guess the good thing is that I
remember the puzzles relax trees okay I
have a feeling I should know it's the
same room okay here we are awesome hi
it's very dark very spooky here's a
cogwheel yay when will it be my turn
have I not shown restraint my patience
spans centuries from where I came
mankind has not have been wasted a
breath yet I bow to you I have done so
much for you and I have gained nothing
in return
Agrippa I trusted you it was I who women
who in all fairness should have entered
that gate so Agrippa did some work
previous isn't that right that could be
it hey Owen hey flow cycle rod you ever
heard of one of those of course you have
elevator machine instructions if the
elevator breaks down again make sure you
use the steam engine to build up the
pressure before channeling you needed to
machinery and just a lever to the red
Amanda pressure inside the chamber the
meters read up eight down eight make
sure the flow is set according to the
following oh yeah this is a very
important note Trinity stream set
function for phase amplitude complete
steam flow cycle if you have to find all
the rods I remember this
Hey look tinderbox hey we found another
way around I hope that was Alexander's
mom all right so I'm coming back I'm
coming back doggy all right can you
chill can you chill your boy is trying
to again if this is me I would just jump
I just realized I can't bring it so
actually it doesn't matter we have to
check in here
I just might as well let's see if
there's notes or something or dogs by
the way you know kill humans all you
want but you kill dogs there's something
wrong that's that's the end of the line
[Music]
you feel that good energy I like it
guest room
[Music]
moving on to the guest
[Applause]
again 2nd of July 1839 I received a
letter today from the Algerian
governor's office disclosing the fate of
Herbert's expedition about a week after
my departure
Abdullah one of the men traveling with
us returned from the desert he was badly
injured as if maimed by a lion smash
rambled deliriously about the expedition
being attacked by something horrible
the French quickly dispatched a search
party to look for the expedition after
certain days they found the camp
abandoned without any trace of Herbert
or his men tomorrow I'll retrieve the
things they recovered from Herbert tent
at the Customs House I don't know what
to make of it but I'm worried for him be
he's carpet got injured why do I care
I don't Hey look
all right we need a lock hey hey there's
so many things he can pick up in this
game doesn't that Raj Phillips it's me
dark you're my brother
I know all right maybe we got a crowbar
yes you need a trick and it's 3rd of
July 1839 today I picked up Herbert's
things of the customs house they dug
through the trove of documents he had
carried and the rock detailing the
expedition the nature of this text
ranged from quick notes to colorful
accounts of transpired events I skimmed
the pages trying to figure out what
might have happened May 17th the day I
was trapped inside the orb chamber
Herbert dryly States recovered Daniel
after one hour of entrapment this
confirm immediately I was suffocating
within minutes how could I have lasted
an hour I continued reading the peculiar
text Herbert states his facts without
judgment or passion but suddenly I could
read frustration into his text he pushed
his men to investigate the underground
tomb an effort which seems to have
strained the minds of his men madness
spread through the ranks and Herbert had
to take some extreme measures to
continue
he finally visits the chamber himself
where he retrieves the orb to the
surface his account confuses me greatly
if he has the orb oh yeah those pieces
in my drawing room
my hentai collection
nice shirt very nice yeah hey be quiet
so there's one more room oh yes of
course
oh yeah I got a star on let's make it
cozy let's make it nice 4th of July 1839
it's done The Orb is assembled I was
awakened by an exhausting nightmare
shaking and sweating I retired to the
drawing room and a cup of tea the relic
pieces lay spread across the table as
I'd left them but somehow I knew how it
was supposed to be I fetched the tile
which I prepared to fix the pieces
together and without fault I joined them
producing the orb
I remembered so clearly the Thar proved
unnecessary it was pushed out from the
joining pieces as they merged on their
own with no adhesive I came as that big
the ancient stone relic now rests on my
table
it's a macular surface and perfect shape
could have been moulded by a factory
this is all too strange dude
I bet you can order their poop oh god oh
god oh yeah I remember I remember it's
fine it's fine you just got it Marcus
that's it oh jeez
why do you let yourself into
oh [ __ ] don't tell me have to go in here
no no no no no
I knew
I think that's a hook bazinga
I'm alive what the Frick is is that God
there it is I guess it is a good place
to hide it man
look at that so we have the machine room
key so that's where we'll go next I have
a confession to make guys I haven't been
playing on hard mode I just realised
hard mode is for when you really know
hard mode is like a challenge it's like
when you're it's like when you're
finished with a game and you want to
speedrun it or like you want to show off
how good you are at the beat in the game
but it doesn't really add to the
immersion I thought it would but I
realize it will just it will just change
what it is I want to replay the game and
feel the immersion I don't want to I
don't want to replay the game and make
it all about the challenge maybe I'll
play hard mode after I finish this
playthrough as a live stream I think it
fits in more cuz there's probably gonna
it's this where we going machinery oh
god I hope it's not down here I remember
this awful place
okay I think we have to go there anyway
all right we'll go there next episode
then let me know what you think I think
this is the right choice anyway either
way thank you guys a million for all the
likes and support and comments on this
series I really really really enjoy it
and I it's great to have you guys along
in this journey I'll see you in three
days with the next episode
[Music]